this was amazing but you want to set
this up for everyone that doesn't know
this this this dabbling john is my new
favorite vegan so this popped up over
the weekend
and i was getting tagged in this a lot
um
our good pal stuttering john
was on uh chrissy maher's show and she's
on
compound she's one of the compound
people she does a couple shows on there
um i worked with uh chrissy moore like
10 years ago she was a stripper she was
a
little maybe she was at the at the
brokerage when um
punchy and hammy came up to hang out
and see me do uh it was at the other
brokerage on long island but yeah so
she's stand up comics she does a podcast
and everything and she uh
she had stuttering john on and this went
really really badly and honestly
none of it was chrissy mart's fault
uh um
so let's just play it yeah yes okay here
we go
trump has been good for comedy
is he frozen is this holy gonna be about
trump or
is he already mad yeah he's already mad
the whole interview is about trump
because every time i tune into your
shows john you're
bitching about trump am i wrong and
that's the only reason she brought it up
uh if you really don't want to talk
about it i just figured uh
no i i thought you had done i thought
you had dabbled occasionally in stand-up
so that's why
so you already know what's gonna happen
i don't i don't want to play the rest of
it oh you have to i don't want to oh
yeah i don't want to oh yeah
i don't want to you have to i don't want
to you have to all right
no i thought you had done i thought you
had dabbled occasionally in a stand up
so that's why i brought that up i
dabbled occasionally really
yeah i didn't know it was if it was a
thing you were really doing or not and
[Laughter]
by the way i wanted to say this i don't
mean this to be a dick
um
the chrissy chrissie's not a great
interviewer anyway like you can tell
she's just kind of like
whatever jon's on so she's not she's
just talking about
treating him with the white glove
service that john thinks he deserves
you know she's just going like i don't
know what do you want from me i thought
you dabbled in comedy like
[ __ ] do you want me to do you want to
hold your hand through this i'm supposed
to know everything
yeah i didn't know it was if it was a
thing you were really doing or not and
you know i wasn't sure
no no i've been doing stand up for 20
years i don't know okay
okay that's good
that's good
it's still by the way have you been
getting it by the way royce didn't pause
it i want to point that
that wasn't me that was not a pause or
anything that's just how it happened on
live
good have you been getting up much
in the last six months or so
well since all my gigs have been
canceled due to covert uh no no i
haven't
but i had i had like you know
15 probably more 20 gigs canceled
yeah yeah a lot of the states have been
up opening up here and there like north
carolina is back open i just didn't know
if you know
the states that had sort of been making
it work with the
you know 25 percent um
you know customers allowed in like if
you were able to you know
rebook anything in the last few months
since things have opened up again
but you know what christy to say i
dabbled in stand-up just
he's not letting it go he's not like
it's that it's back around to the
dabbling thing
like you would have thought okay we've
moved on from dabbling yeah
we we got it we were in a little bit of
a [ __ ] you know we're in a little bit
of a pothole there but hey we got out of
it we're moving on nope
he's right back to the but the the funny
thing like i'm funny how like how
like like i'm uh like i talk
in the last few months since things have
opened up again but you know what
christy to say i dabbled in stand up is
so disrespectful
no no no no she knows what she said
anthony she knows what she said
she's a big boy what'd you say say you
said it
i haven't been disrespectful to you at
all he's drunk too and yet you
respect me and say i don't know i didn't
i i mean i could have picked a different
word i didn't know that it was your main
thing
honestly okay
she's just i mean
i mean that's so disrespectful and i'm
doing his job
who cares and i love that i love
that mentality and i'm doing your show
like who gives a [ __ ]
the reason you do people show the people
because you were on stern i mean that
that's
that's the reason you know you were name
on stern you know the jay leno thing
but does he think that chrissy maher is
getting like some kind of big old she's
getting the [ __ ] stuttering john bump
because he's on the show well he does
sell cocaine does she yes
but does he think does he picture it
like when he's doing his show for
[ __ ] 18 people
right does he think that maybe all the
people just don't only show up when he's
on other people's [ __ ] does he think
that's bringing a big crowd with him
i i i honestly i don't know the extent
to which you do
stand up i mean isn't that the point of
an interview is like oh you can correct
me if i'm wrong about it no no no
you dabble didn't stand up yeah i don't
know
i didn't know i don't know how much
stand up you do john it's it was just
another
one yeah i dabbled and stand up
come on that's a come on so you're more
than a dabbler
i didn't see that part she's handling it
pretty well again
i'm giving a credit here i know i
watched the shorter clip
i haven't see i sent this one in just
because it was a longer one i did not
hear the part
we're christy morrowind so you're more
than a dabbler
it's okay i don't hey i've been wrong
it's fine
it's like it's really not a big deal you
probably didn't know that i did stand up
it's okay it's you know we're not like
uh that's what an interview is
learn more about the other person so
well you seem to be pretty um
schooled in everything else so you would
think that you've seen that he's not
letting it go be
see you see how this is a [ __ ] cares
this is a [ __ ]
a lesson right here everybody listen to
this
this is a perfect lesson in how not to
handle a situation
if you feel slighted just let it go or
or
if you are going to point it out like be
funny about it
like don't be like angry you know what i
mean like he's really pissed and he
keeps going like
no i want to go back to the thing where
you called me a dabbler
we said i'm a dabbler i don't dabble i'm
not a dabble i do want to dabble
but the way to handle that is somebody's
like i mean obviously i've never done
stand-up but if somebody were to say to
me oh
and let's see if it was a stand-up so
i'm gonna go to meow so you dabble and
stand and be like yeah that's what it
feels like sometimes
joke make fun of yourself who cares like
he's getting really mad yeah or even
just laugh like you go
dabble i i dabble like where you go
jesus christ
and you you act offended but you do it
in a way where you're like
jesus [ __ ] christ i dabble no you're
right i guess
i guess and then passively aggressively
throughout the show you could go
yeah i also dabble a little bit in uh in
podcasting
can i promote the show so i can dabble
to more people
like you could be funny about it but he
just keeps going like
like he's doing it the way you fight
when you're in a couple where the
couple's kind of already on it's like
last legs and you're just fighting over
every little thing you're like
no no no no no i want to go back let's
let's double back around i want to go
back to where you said i
dabble that's like jesus christ that was
an hour ago
you still want to talk about that well
thank you i wanted to
prepare so i feel like you know but i
don't
i don't know all there is to know about
john so
hence the interview
um so i guess all right so you don't
want to talk about it
she's so she's like i've been there and
you've been there you know that feeling
of like okay so what else
you just gotta go what else no i'll talk
about him but i don't know why
i mean i didn't know this was going to
be political you know
oh no that's that was not my goal either
i've talked with a bunch of other
comedians some people say he's he has
been great for comedy some people think
uh the trump jokes are getting a little
tired it's
it's a question that i was asking
without it being like a triggering you
know
you know of you as a comedian
you know you're a comedian right yes i
dabble
[Laughter]
there's no better answer that's
a whole that's a home run that's
objectively a home run
that's a that's you're just watching the
ball go into the parking lot you're like
i was
he he
[ __ ] set her up
how did he not see that coming
how did he not telegraph that
wow how did he not telegraph that when
he said that
holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
can we can we watch that again i have to
just the last part just that last part
i'm tired it's it's a question that i
was asking without it being
like a triggering you know
you know of you as a comedian
you know you're a comedian right yes i
dabble
and that's where the that's where the
video ends
i didn't hear the ideal part i i
didn't hear the i didn't hear that part
when i heard the original clip that's
[ __ ] hilarious
like that like that there's no what do
you say after that
that is somebody goes a smiling child
just got handed a baseball at the
car but by the car park attendant there
that was that was out of the stadium it
was
yeah it was just it was an easy one
but sometimes the easy ones are the best
ones no the easiest ones are always the
best one
i mean that was like that was a one in a
million setup right there that
somebody just put that ball right in the
strike zone right in the middle of the
strike zone right down the middle
and just wham what a dumb [ __ ] john is
jesus christ man yeah but that people
would enjoy that that make my weekend
the whole you know i'm one of just a
dabbler
i was like god john is spiraling over
this
that was that was just next next level i
dabbled yeah like what do you say after
that it's like all right i'm gonna go
at this point somebody's saying royce is
an evil man i didn't bring i'm not the
one that brought this to the show by the
way this was
this was sent to mike and he gave it to
me i i this is just me playing
it yeah i've been trying to i've been
keeping tabs on john because john really
is a
gift the gift that keeps on giving he
just keeps and it's weird because he's
still
like people know that name they still
know that name of course
they always will so there's a lot of
people who haven't been
caught up on him that just see like hey
i'm stuttering john i used to be on
howard stern anyway you want to come to
my youtube show
people are just people are just thinking
wow howard stern
wow youtube's really hot right now this
john guy must be killing it and they
come on a show
and it's like guest after guest where
they have these guys that come on and
he's like
so with me right now is i've got uh
political correspondent and author noam
chomsky
hey no you know we're talking about
trump recently you know when that
[ __ ] kumia
you know he's always disrespecting me
he's a real piece of [ __ ] you know that
[ __ ] kumia
you know i've been nothing but nice to
this guy and he's political guys just
come on the show and go
and there's a lot of this move you know
the move where the eyes where you look
off
off camera there's a lot of that where
people are going um
yeah yeah it's like all these compound
media guys like what
i never did nothing to you and these
guys are all going
ok ok um did you want to talk about
trump or
it's really [ __ ] funny anyway that
[ __ ] i dabble
it's the [ __ ] greatest it was good
job jeez
that not the best way to handle it
john's just spiraling somebody michael
being in the chat says who are these
podcasts are going to [ __ ] kill him
for this
and the thing is like even you could
tell like even chrissy maher tried to
give him an
out like three times right like she was
like yeah
so anyway we could talk about that and
he's like nah but i want to talk about
the dabbling thing again and it's like
john she's letting you out right now you
look like a dick
nobody's going to come off looking good
in this just leave it alone and he's
not but it's like you know i do a lot of
stand-up comedy she's like who cares
dude
so it's dabbling john now yeah i know
for
now and forever i mean he did it himself
really
uh definitely not the best way to handle
it